[Music]
like
the revisionist history like the quick
history we have of native americans is
that they were like
one with nature and peaceful right and
it's just it's like
it's actually borderline races where
you're taking away the agency of them
right they were people right they were
shitty right they were just as shitty
right so you know they had issues yeah
like well like because i think like most
people don't know because you read this
book
but like most people think i know i
think like
america uh you know the united states
came in ripped these good
you know nature loving native americans
from their land put them on reservations
and we owe them
everything like we are horrible so
horrible to them which i'm sure is all
true i know that oh yeah that is all
true
yeah but the problem is is that the
comanches
is it just one tribe of the native
americans the comanches were bad or like
did you learn that like a
bunch of them yeah yeah there's a ton
there's
i mean there was so many tribes they
were
like the comanche when they started not
start but like the early like the early
records of the comanche were like they
were kind of up in like the rockies
and they were they were little tiny guys
that's another thing
squeaks we call them the show like uh
yeah because we have this version of
native americans that are like the
northeastern you know the woodland
tribes where they're all like avatars
right like long and a sinuon you know
sin
how do i say that word i don't know i've
never heard of it cinnabon
cinnamony long avatar people long avatar
people okay
but then you head out west and they were
they were much more like mexicans right
just little squeaks tiny guys those were
the comanches were the squeaks the
comanches were the squeaks but they were
[ __ ]
and they sucked for a while and then and
then when the spanish came over
brought the horses and then the horses
would start to escape and get out
and certain tribes didn't know what to
do like the apache were just eating the
horses
really they weren't sure how these
things are good
we're gonna keep munching these yeah and
then the comanche started riding them
and got like
incredible at it and then so for like
centuries they were the lowest on the
pack more and they would get [ __ ] up
by
everybody yeah the comanches would get
rocked by everybody and then they got
horses
and just they got revenge dude they
combined out right all the people that
were picking on them
got paid for it they got it they got it
hard
wow i it's it's crazy to think back in
history like yeah that's just what it is
like
news of something just took months yeah
some guy had to like walk
to st louis yeah there's a bunch of guys
coming yeah
like 40 years later yeah she's right i
see one white dude yeah
it's like i always would think too like
writing letters like in the civil war
like a soldier writing a letter to like
his mom or wife and be like i'm alive
i'm great or survive this about and then
it gets their form and saying it's like
no dude you died a day like
it's like as a as their wife i'd be like
i don't believe that like
are you alive or dead i always thought
about that
because it just takes too long for me to
[ __ ] know if that like i would just
be sitting in constant anxiety
yeah if you were in the civil war yeah
for sure
definitely yeah there was a gun in the
civil war called the devil's breath i
was like i don't want to smell that
would suck
a lady threw up in the front row during
one really yeah wine
she tried to sneak and throw up she was
like
you just rolled down her shirt dude just
call her out
holy [ __ ] that lady's throwing up
yeah you guys never seen a [ __ ] horse
yeah i thought you're gonna do what we
say
yeah i would dude i would have [ __ ]
just been like i literally if i was
christopher columbus when i got off
on the shores with that horse i would
have [ __ ] taken that horse right into
the shores
let the native all the native americans
see me and then just start sucking that
horse's dick
just to show them that i'm in charge
just right in front of just
on the knees double barrel blow job and
let that and
shoot let that horse shoot it slow all
over my face and then just get up and be
like i'm your master now
yeah it would work absolutely i mean
that would hold up today if i saw a guy
pull up off a boat with a horse
and [ __ ] it i'd be like i'm gonna listen
to what he's got
exactly yeah he's got some ideas yeah
because comanches had did they have like
writing or an alphabet
no no no they used like most of these
tribes used like knots on a string
to like communicate i don't know how the
[ __ ] it even works they'd be like this
is time
really they say they had like beads to
be like here's our story
gave us a necklace yeah but yeah it's
the history of our tribe
what we're gonna write we're gonna go
ahead and write your history yeah just
read it
[Music]
huh